date vous ne fumez peut-être plus
patricia a décidé de s'arrêter à la fin
de ce journal
et il ne fait pas bon de fumer en public
en ce moment aux états unis c'est à une
véritable croisade que se livrent les
pouvoirs publics pour lutter contre les
mangeurs de nicotine entre guillemets
dans près de 40 et américains il est
interdit de fumer dans les lieux publics
de très nombreuses entreprises privées
interdisent à leurs salariés d'allumer
une cigarette
doit-il reportage de shaka bouchard aux
états unis comme elle semble loin
l'époque où la publicité associée à la
cigarette à l'idée de séduction et les
chasser banni des écrans de télévision
américains depuis 1970 les activistes
anti tabac sont lancés dans une nouvelle
offensive et 40 des 50 états américains
interdisent de fumer dans la plupart des
endroits publics bus train banques
écoles magasins bureaux de poste les
entreprises mènent la vie dure aux
fumeurs priés d'aller assouvir leur
passion en dehors des locaux
professionnels
ces deux employés de seattle ont donc
trouvé un ultime refuge dans la cage
d'escalier
c'est scandaleux on devrait pouvoir
fumer dans un endroit décent estime une
de leurs collègues
cette femme résiste encore dans son
bureau
mais elle a déjà reçu un ultimatum
bientôt pour allumer une cigarette
elle devra descendre les 32 étages de la
tour où elle travaille pour se rendre
dans l'unique pièce réservée aux fumeurs
à beverly hills un quartier de los
angeles
le conseil municipal vient de prendre
une décision historique sous les
applaudissements interdiction totale de
fumer dans tous les restaurants de la
commune
les commerçants s'assure devant cette
mesure ils jugent suicidaire pour leurs
affaires
c'est très simple dit ce restaurateur
nos clients iront ailleurs de nombreux
restaurants à travers les états unis ont
déjà établi des zones fumeurs et non
fumeurs
ils redoutent que l'exemple de beverly
hills ne fasse tache d'huile
si c'était comme en californie interdit
complètement quel serait le problème
trois quarts des volumes par le froid
car la moitié pour en finir avec le
tabagisme
certaines sociétés proposent des
traitements gratuits à leurs personnels
il en existe un grand nombre
celui ci cherche à dégoûter le fumeur
qui reçoit de brève décharge électrique
dès qu'ils tirent sur la cigarette
le grand manitou de la croisade actuelle
et le docteur everett coupe chef des
services fédéraux de santé ars est son
ambition dit il éliminer complètement le
tabac de la société américaine à
l'horizon de l'an 2000 selon les
chiffres officiels la cigarette tue
chaque année 320 mille personnes aux
états unis
83 % de ces morts résultant d'un cancer
du poumon
depuis dix ans la proportion des fumeurs
est tombée de 42 à 30 % de la population
adulte des états unis ce qui représente
quand même encore 53 millions de
personnes malgré ce recul les fabricants
de cigarettes reconnaissent d'ailleurs
que leur chiffre d'affaires comme leurs
bénéfices se porte plutôt bien